Well, we can convert a slope-intercept form and do it that way. I have negative
5y in the left and negative 7x plus 3 on the right. Remember, I can't combine
these because this doesn't have an x, these are not like terms. Next we divide
every term by negative 5 to get y equals 7 5ths x plus negative 3 5ths.. I have
a minus sign here, so I know the second term is really just a negative. Our
equation is in slope-intercept form, so our slope must be 7 5ths. Well done if
you got that one. If you thought about it in terms of standard form, you would
have done negative A divided by B. You want to be really careful though. This is
not in standard form. We need to write it in standard form first. The x term
should come first. I can switch the place of the 7x and the negative 5y and I
get this equation. Notice, the 7x is still positive and the 5y is still
negative. So A is positive 7 and B is negative 5. A negative divided by a
negative makes a positive, so I get 7 5ths, still the correct answer.